counter terrorism
on its own
won't remove an entrenched threat
we need some boots on the ground
naturally our preference is for the
boots to be local
but that will not always be possible
western societies and their political
leaders
have become
quite understandably deeply averse to
casualties amongst our armed forces
this is not a problem for the armed
forces themselves
who are brave and extraordinary people
but it is now an overwhelming political
constraint
to any commitment to western boots on
the ground except for special forces
yet the problem disc is rise to
is obvious
if the enemy were fighting knows that
the more casualties they inflict
the more our political will erodes
then the instrument incentive structure
is playing one of the most depressing
things i've
heard regularly
articulated over the past weeks
is the idea that we are foolish in
believing that western notions of
liberal democracy and freedom
are exportable
or will ever take root
except in the somewhat decadent terrain
of western society
now maybe my generation of leaders
were naive and thinking countries could
be remade
or maybe the remaking needed to last
longer
but we should never forget
as we see the women of afghanistan
in the media culture and civic society
now flee in fear of their lives
that our values are still those which
free people choose
recovering confidence in those values
and in their universal application
is a necessary part
of ensuring we stand up for them
and are prepared to defend them